- Vroom vroom, vroom vroom.
Okay, Elmo's ready!
- Oh wait, I'm almost ready.
Um, there.
Okay.
- Yeah, ready?
(both giggle)
The Elmo-mobile.
- And the Zoe-mobile!
- Three, two, one!
- Yeah baby! Boy, Elmo's ramp worked! Yeah (laughs).
- Well mine didn't work!
I need a do-over!
- Okay, do-over, do-over (laughs)
- All right, three, two, one, woo.
What? Oh!
It, it didn't work again!
- Well, you know that's okay, Zoe.
Zoe can play with Elmo's ramp.
Elmo's ramp works great!
- Well thanks, Elmo.
Boy, I guess I'm just no good at building ramps!
- Sorry.
- Hi Elmo, hi Zoe.
- Oh, hi Mr Sal.
- What's wrong Zoe?
- Oh, my ramp doesn't work.
I'm just gonna go play with Elmo's ramp.
- Oh, hold on a second.
Any great engineering project is gonna involve
some trial and error.
It's not that your ramp doesn't work,
it's just that it doesn't work yet!
That's the power of 'yet'.
- Woo, oh, Mr. Sal?
Is that like a super power?
- Kind of Elmo.
It's a super power that we all have.
It's the idea that mistakes aren't bad,
and that we learn from them,
so we keep trying.
- But I tried my ramp twice already.
- Well what did you try differently the second time?
- Nothing.
- Well why don't we look closer
and see if we can try a different approach?
And even if that doesn't work, it's okay.
We'll learn from it.
- Ooh!
- Okay, well, the Zoe-mobile crashed right here.
- [Elmo] Yeah?
- So maybe I need to just fill this hole.
- That's a good idea.
- I think I have a block that'll do just the trick.
Here, wait.
- Ooh!
- There you go, Zoe, I like the way you're thinking.
Like the great engineer that you are.
- Ah, all right!
Here, let me try.
- [Elmo] Okay.
- Come here, Zoe-mobile.
Here we go!
- Oh boy.
- Oh, no!
Oh, that's it, I'm just giving up.
- No, no, no, no, no!
Not if you believe in the power of 'yet'.
You know how your muscles get stronger when you exercise?
- Oh yeah, I'm super strong.
Watch this.
- Oh, Elmo too.
- Exactly!
Making mistakes and coming up with solutions
to solve your problems is exercise for your brain.
- Whoa! It's brainercize!
- Right! When you believe you can do it and you keep trying,
that's when your brain is growing and you're learning
new things.
- Wow!
- It's called a growth mindset.
- Okay, well then, I'm gonna try again!
- Okay Zoe!
- Now let's see.
That time the Zoe-mobile crashed right here.
- Right.
- So maybe if I get rid of this block.
- Yeah, ooh.
- Oh hey!
Look at that nice straight line all the way down!
- Ah, uh huh!
- I'll bet that'll do it!
Here let me try.
- Okay.
- Come here Zoe-mobile.
Here we go!
- Yay! Good job Zoe!
Oh boy, the Zoe-mobile went so fast!
- Yeah!
Hey, can Zoe make Elmo's ramp taller and faster too?
- Yeah, let's do it together!
- Yeah, okay!
- Great job guys.
I'm so proud that you kept trying,
and you weren't afraid to make mistakes.
And because of it we all learned a ton.
And that's the power of 'yet'.
- Yeah! Come on Zoe, let's play.
- Alright!
- Okay so, maybe if there's like something here?